well US governor's are sounding the
alarm saying our trajectory is basically
the same as what they had in Italy whoa
CBS News medical contributor dr. Tara
Narula is here to answer your biggest
questions about the virus Tara welcome
back I hope that's not true do you feel
that too well I think we need to pay
attention to that learn from that
exactly we've got this question a lot
we're gonna take KC's though what does
it mean for pregnant women women the
coronavirus yeah a lot of pregnant women
concerned so you know unfortunately this
virus has only been around for a couple
months so we really don't have the
long-term data to tell us a lot so far
it does not seem that pregnant women are
more at risk or will suffer more severe
disease that being said with other viral
illnesses like the flu for example women
who are pregnant can develop more severe
disease so we really need a lot more
data to inform us in addition it does
not seem at this point in time that
pregnant women can pass the virus on to
the baby it's not has not been found in
the amniotic fluid or in the breast milk
but again all of the science is really
evolving and we will need to to look
forward as we've got a question from
Shannon on Twitter who asked allergy
season is here since it appears some
have mild symptoms when infected with
the virus how do we know the difference
between allergies and the virus my son
asked me this when we were out for a
walk the other day yeah so I mean some
of the symptoms can overlap first you
want to think about the fact that with
allergies it tends to be more chronic
lasting kind of weeks or months more
seasonal maybe has some changes with the
environment that you're in and allergies
tend to be more the sneezing runny
stuffy nose itchy watery eyes with kovat
you're really gonna have fever which you
shouldn't have with allergies more of
the shortness of breath more of that dry
cough with allergies you may get a cop
if you have some post nasal drip but
less less common and then more systemic
systems with kovat like the headache and
the muscle aches and the fatigue
delivery services particularly takeout
food delivery overdrive right now yeah
you know so we've got a question here
which i think is a great one this is
from a viewer on Instagram asking should
we be concerned about our food sources
and the people dropping them off yeah I
think about this every night because my
husband and I order in every night
one of the things you want to understand
is that so far there's really been no
evidence that kovat can be transmitted
through food or through food packaging
that being said if you want to take
precautions con when you have the driver
deliver or whoever's delivering leave it
outside the door you can leave the money
out there so you don't actually have
that face-to-face interaction you're so
rude those of us and then when you take
the packaging in because we do know that
there can be some droplets on surfaces
that we have to pay attention to you
want to bring it somewhere that's not in
the area you're gonna be eating discard
the packaging take the food out and
don't use the containers or the utensils
that came in the bag put it in your own
and then clean the surface where you put
that down and wash your hands I'm using
hand sanitizer as a nice light
vinaigrette yes
[Laughter]